[Musique]
il ya 150 ans charles darwin publie son
deuxième grand ouvrage il contient deux
idées créée celle que l'humain est le
cousin du sage et que l'extravagance est
aussi un moteur de l'évolution
douze ans plus tôt darwin avait établi à
mettre l'origine des espèces
le concept de sélection naturelle pour
expliquer pourquoi certains animaux ont
un coût très long un mec très durs ou
des couleurs plutôt discrète
à chaque génération
le hasard introduit de petites
différences entre les individus
si cette différence augmente les chances
de survie de certains leur descendance
sera plus nombreuses au fil du temps cet
avantage va se répandre dans la
population
c'est donc la nature qui sélectionne ce
qui tue team
non ce qui oriente évolution d'une
espèce
[Musique]
mais darwin prend bien soin de ne pas
appliquer ses idées à l'humain un sujet
épineux
surtout en pleine époque victorienne en
1871 ya 150 ans il met la touche finale
à son livre de 120 darwin y relève les
ressemblances entre les humains et
d'autres animaux sur le plan de
l'anatomie de l'embryologie mais aussi
des comportements
il fait valoir que certains animaux sont
eux aussi preuve d'altruisme ou
d'intelligence
[Musique]
les humains font partie du règne animal
ils ont un ancêtre commun avec les
singes actuels
cela suppose aussi que les humains
continuent d'évoluer et dans les
sociétés modernes
on protège les plus vulnérables et on
soigne les malades
alors si tout le monde peut se
reproduire
qu'est ce qui guide l'évolution charles
darwin propose donc un deuxième
mécanisme la sélection sexuelle
après tout ce sont les femmes qui
choisissent quel homme rond tout non une
descendance selon lui leur préférence
aurait donné naissance aux différentes
ethnies
darwin s'appuie sur des exemples tirés
du monde animal et notamment sur les
extravagances de certainement
si les immenses cornes des scarabées
sont utiles pourquoi la femelle n'en
appelle pas pourquoi y at il des plumes
qui n'aide pas à voler et des panaches
qui nuisent carrément aux déplacements
darwin soutient que la réponse se trouve
dans l'oeil de celles qui regardent pour
la femelle ce sont des indices des mâles
exceptionnel au fil des générations
la sélection conserve donc ce qui est
utile mais elle encourage aussi
certaines excentricités de là à faire un
parallèle avec les comportements humains
il y avait évidemment des limites
si ce n'est peut-être que tous les goûts
sont dans la nature
[Musique]